you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
too hot to fly the fire fighting planes
evidence of the extreme conditions we'll
increasingly face
with wildfires across southern europe
and in the united states and south
america
more heat waves more droughts more
cyclones a stark warning for the future
of
india but is the world's third biggest
emitter
ready to play its part at cop26
and if we can do it why can't everyone
the island of northern ireland that aims
to be
self-sufficient in renewable energy by
the end of the decade
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
the warning from the intergovernmental
panel on climate change was stark and
shocking and we start today with
evidence of just how severe the impact
of climate change is
right now well in a moment we'll look at
what it could mean
for india but first to the increasingly
disturbing pattern
of extreme wildfires across the world
and whilst there have always been
wildfires we know from the ipcc report
that more extreme
extensive and destructive fires are the
harsh reality of climate change
well wildfires in parts of greece
including evia island near athens have
been burning for days now and there are
increasing concerns about fires in
puglia calabria and sicily
in italy there's also the huge
dixie fire in california and now
fast-growing fires in several countries
in south america including
peru and bolivia meanwhile wildfires are
still raging in parts of siberia in
russia
and four people have died in wildfires
in algeria
well this is the scene from bolivia
where fires have swept across the
eastern lowlands in the department of
santa cruz an area known for its rich
wildlife
this year forest fires have consumed
more than 360 thousand acres in the area
and in peru fires have started in the
city of cushco in the andes
air force helicopters have been called
in to drop water over the fires that
started on thursday
in russia there have been 155 forest
fires across
a large area of siberia two villages
have been evacuated
and dozens more are threatened while
buildings and houses have been
destroyed in greece the prime minister
kiriakos mitsutakis has apologized for
failures in tackling the wildfires
that have burned across the country for
days and approved a further
500 million euros for relief and
compensation
well sky's michelle clifford has the
latest from evia the hard-hit island
near athens
and michelle the prime minister there
has called this a natural disaster of
unprecedented dimensions
how are attempts to control the fires
they're now faring
they're still really difficult to weak
on the fires are still blazing
uh in greece and on here on the island
of
evia we hear a constant stream of
firefighting
helicopters going overhead trying to
douse the land uh with water but there
are incredibly high temperatures
today and that's made the task all the
harder uh firefighters from
other european nations and further
afield have now come
to greece to help with the effort but as
you mentioned
the uh greek prime minister has gone on
television and he's apologized
for some of the government failings in
terms of the response he also talked
about
a lack of being prepared for such a
catastrophic situation and he issued
a warning saying that the climate crisis
is knocking on the door
of the entire planet and i suppose anna
that
is a reminder of what experts have been
warning off for a very long time
that what we've seen in europe over
recent weeks be it flooding
or be it wildfires extremes of weather
and temperature
are going to be more frequent in the
future and the warning is
that governments and leaders really need
to be prepared
mitchell clifford thank you well let's
turn out to india
crucial in the story of climate change
yesterday's ipcc report
said the indian subcontinent will face
far more extreme weather
and is likely to suffer from more severe
heat stress and flooding
soon to overtake china as the most
populous nation india is also the third
biggest emitter on the planet so must
play a significant role if the world is
to tackle the crisis
well the ipcc report says india will
face more
heat waves and humid heat stress will be
more intense and frequent
in this century than the last the report
also says
that the decrease in rainfall from the
south and southeast monsoon in
recent decades is due to human activity
but that in the long term
the country will face more heavy monsoon
rainfall
now the indian ocean is heating faster
than other areas and the sea level is
rising
at 3.7 millimeters every year now that
means extreme sea level events that used
to take place once a century
will now happen nearly every year but
india is not just a victim of climate
change
it's a major emitter and its future
emissions will be a hotly contested part
of any deal at cop26 now
china overtook the us to become the
world's biggest emitter
in 2006. so india is now in
third place and responsible for 7
of the world's co2 emissions india
says western developed nations must
shoulder the greatest burden in reducing
emissions and argues
the ipcc report vindicates its position
well let's get a sense of the mood in
delhi a crucial player at cop 26
our indie correspondent neville lazarus
is in the indian capital
so neville what is the reaction to the
ipcc report there in india
has that its stark warning had an impact
on the country's willingness to
to make changes at cop26 the report
hasn't
has been talked about in the newspapers
in in television studios on the news but
that's where it ends there hasn't been
much of reaction from the government in
fact there's been very slow inclination
of the speed and scope of of
the efforts from the government in terms
of mitigating
uh climate change we've seen we just
moved from one catastrophe to the next
it's one
cyclone to the to the flooding or or to
a massive heat wave or glacial
uh sort of breaches which have killed
hundreds of people and so
uh there hasn't been much effort from
the government to show
or or to talk about it it it we just
move on from one
one uh one uh one catastroph trophy to
the to the next and
we do have now a new minister who's uh
who came in last month he's an enviro
he's he's a lawyer he's uh he's an
environmentalist he's uh
he's co authored a book on environment
uh he has talked about decoupling
emissions
and uh and and economic progress
and we hope that there will be a change
but it has to be
has to be done really really fast and
the scope has to be
uh has to be across this country because
we're dealing with the country which is
almost 2000
miles from north to south and east west
with a really
large and long coastal uh
coastal belts and coastal region which
uh which
where there are millions of people
living and and each
each month they are being battered by
some sort of climate change
and environmental hazard never lazarus
thanks very much indeed
in today's other climate news 84 of
people in wales believe they need to
make substantial lifestyle changes to
address climate change
that's the finding of a new survey by
the welsh government that showed only 15
of respondents thought climate change
will affect their local area a great
deal
that's in stark contrast to the latest
ipcc report
which warns that rising sea levels will
affect coastlines in wales and lead to
the significant relocation of
communities there
just nine percent of small firms measure
their carbon footprint
falling to just five percent for micro
businesses
a new survey of members by the british
chambers of commerce
shows many smaller companies are
struggling to get to grips with their
own carbon emissions
a new service has been launched with o2
to help smaller firms get information
about transitioning
to net zero and life-sized
lion sculptures have appeared in london
as part of a global art installation
launched in support of conservation
across the african continent
the sculptures aim to highlight the
threats faced by lions such as climate
change
while raising funds for community
conservation climate change is driving
habitat loss
and increasing droughts in countries
like kenya and botswana
leading to conflict between humans and
lions
wrestling island six miles off the coast
of northern ireland
wasn't connected to the electricity grid
until 2007
but aims to produce its own wind and
wave energy
by the end of the decade residents say
if it can be achieved at this remote
location on the end of the grid
it can be achieved anywhere ahead of the
target our senior island correspondent
david blevins reports from ratlin island
it's the most northern part of northern
ireland
and it's easy to see why wrathlyn is
concerned about the climate crisis
the island wasn't connected to the grid
until 2007
but aims to be carbon neutral by the end
of this decade
there's great possibilities now with
hydrogen fueled ferries and
and we can produce hydrogen on our often
so i mean that
achieves two goals it reduces our carbon
footprint hopefully to zero but it also
gives us some security and that we're
generating
our own energy and retailing our own
energy
kate burns is an underwater farmer she's
battling climate change
by harnessing the potential in seaweed
these seeds are swimming in kelp
and it's as rich in protein as beef
there is as much protein in kelp and
also
it's higher in calcium and iron than any
other vegetable including spinach
and you know the thing about kelp is you
grow it in the sea
you don't need any fertilizers or any
pesticides or any herbicides
in fact the more you grow the better it
is for the environment
tom's passion for wildlife photography
has taken him around the world
but he keeps coming home to rafflin and
wants to see his subjects protected
there has to be a change at some stage
and we need to do it
sooner rather than later because i mean
you just see with the news or the fires
in the world and the heating up of
things
possibly see temperatures rising you
know it's not looking too good at the
moment
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
but islanders want others to share their
aspiration for carbon neutrality
they say if it can be achieved here
at the end of the grid it can be
achieved anywhere
residents are deeply conscious that they
share this island
and the waters around it and are
fighting for those who can't fight for
themselves
david blevins sky news on wrathlon
island
rewilding is a word we hear more and
more it's a simple concept but could
play a crucial part in tackling both
climate change
and the biodiversity crisis we now face
a new four-year project has just been
launched to discover the best way to
restore woodland and
meadow habitats in the uk
[Music]
well that's everything from us for today
coming up on tomorrow's show why climate
change is putting the ancient
world at risk of disappearing you can
catch that at the same time here on sky
news
see you then